lleva 27 años recorriendo Londres en su
ambulancia Steve entrará en huelga
regañadientes
no me metí en ese trabajo para hacer una
huelga sino para ayudar a la gente pero
la falta de financiación y los bajos
aumentos salariales hacen que haya
decenas de miles de puestos de trabajo
sin cubrir en el nhs es fantástico el
apoyo de la gente en estos momentos es
reconfortante incluso conmovedor
se unió al equipo en plena crisis del
cobi 19 esta joven trabajadora ha visto
cómo se deterioraba el sistema sanitario
desde su llegada los retrasos para que
acudan los paramédicos son cada vez
mayores y este invierno ha habido récord
en las listas de espera con hospitales
saturados
el real colegio de médicos afirma que se
producen 500 muertes a la semana debido
a los largos retrasos tenemos historias
terribles horribles de pacientes que
esperan en camas de hospital durante 10
12 horas no es aceptable
sabes que es duro pensar que puedes
esperar horas y horas y tu paciente
puede empeorar y no puedes hacer nada
para ayudarlo
empieza el día y enseguida entra una
llamada
[Música]
vale tenemos trabajo que hacer es
Alguien que ha perdido el conocimiento
es tan listos como siempre equipos como
este piden más recursos para salvar
vidas en un clamor sin precedentes en
Reino Unido
[Música]